- [Narrator] These trucks stretching
to the horizon are only a fraction
of the 5.5 million that
entered Laredo, Texas in 2022.
It's one sign of a broader shift
in the global economy as hundreds
of companies around the world
move their manufacturing
from China to here in Mexico,
and as a border town,
that makes Laredo the hub
at the center of a trend
that's changing global markets.
- If you are manufacturing in Mexico,
you can get that product
to the US consumer in
under 24 hours in a truck.
If you are manufacturing in Asia,
it's gonna take you two to six weeks
- [Narrator] Amid an explosion of trade
between Mexico and the
rest of North America,
here's a look at why Laredo
is primed to become one
of the world's most important
land ports and its role
in transforming global supply chains.
On this bridge dividing
the US from Mexico,
trucks often wait hours
for a chance to cross into Laredo.
In 2022, more than $800
million worth of products,
from auto parts to carpets to avocados
passed through the city each day
according to US Census data.
- The total trade between
Mexico and the United States,
40% of that crosses
through the port of Laredo.
- [Narrator] Daniel Covarrubias
has spent years studying Laredo's role
in international trade
at Texas A&M International University.
- If you see on a map
where Laredo is situated
between the United States, the
biggest market in the world
and Mexico one of the
biggest producing markets
in the world, well, it's
right in the middle of it.
- [Narrator] Laredo is uniquely positioned
to handle all this trade
as more and more companies
reduce their dependence
on Chinese factories and
shift production to Mexico.
It's part of a larger
strategy called nearshoring.
- It went from a trend of
globalization to regionalization.
- Economists and executives
say soaring shipping rates,
a trade war between China and the US
and geopolitical uncertainty
caused by Russia's invasion
of Ukraine helped fuel
the nearshoring trend.
Plus, Mexico's free trade
deals mean companies
that make their products
in Mexico can ship them
to the rest of North America duty free.
- You're seeing Chinese companies
to get out of the tariffs
and post on them, well, they
can come and take advantage
of the US-Mexico-Canada trade agreement
if they manufacture in Mexico.
- [Instructor] In 2022, goods traded
between the US and Mexico
reached almost $780 billion,
an increase of nearly 18%
from the previous year.
While Laredo isn't the only
US border town capitalizing
on the expansion of nearshoring,
it's receiving the most activity.
In October 2022, about $27 billion worth
of freight moved through Laredo alone.
That month, it overtook the trade volume
from each of the ocean ports
of Los Angeles and Long Beach.
Executives say part of Laredo's
appeal is its location.
The city is the closest US land port
to some of Mexico's largest
manufacturing centers,
like the Nuevo Leon region,
which includes the massive
industrial city of Monterrey.
- From loading up on a truck in Monterrey,
you have a two and a half hour drive north
from Monterrey until you
hit the Laredo border.
- [Narrator] Tom Simmons
is the vice president
of Majestic Realty,
a privately owned industrial
real estate developer.
Over the last 10 years,
Majestic has invested in warehouse
properties across Laredo.
- That product will get unpacked
in a Laredo warehouse like
we're sitting in right now.
Will get repacked into
outbound trucks and tractors
and will get distributed
throughout the United States,
and you'll have all
of the roadway networks that
will spread east and west.
- [Narrator] The expansion
of trade in Laredo
is fueled by the surge
of foreign direct investment in Mexico
over the last two decades.
Mattel expanded its Monterrey plant
into its largest manufacturing
facility worldwide.
LEGO also operates its
largest factory in Nuevo Leon
with plans to expand, and
Tesla recently announced plans
to build out a massive gigafactory
in the Monterrey region.
And those are just a
small sample of companies
relocating their operations.
The Mexican government said
more than 400 companies
have shown interest
in moving production from Asia to Mexico.
That translates into a surge
of products funneled into
logistics hubs like Laredo.
- If you take a 35-mile radius
and place it here on this
cross-border region of Laredo,
and Nuevo Laredo, you're
gonna find upwards
of 500 US custom brokers and
Mexican custom brokers firms.
You're gonna find more than
500 transportation companies,
more than 350 logistics companies.
- [Narrator] That concentration
of logistics companies
means trucks,
(truck rumbling)
and lots of them.
- More than 15,000 trucks cross daily
by the port of Laredo
and this is between two
bridges, the World Trade Bridge
and the Colombia Bridge.
- [Narrator] The amount of trucks passing
through Laredo has seen a steady increase
over the last 10 years.
To keep up,
large infrastructure
build-outs are underway.
The city has already committed
to expanding the World Trade
Bridge from eight lanes to 16
and the rail company,
Canadian Pacific Kansas City,
broke ground on a project
that will double the capacity
of a rail bridge spanning the Rio Grande.
More trade passing through
Laredo also means greater demand
for warehouse space.
In this warehouse,
thousands of auto parts
are transported in and out
by truck each day.
Just one lot over,
trucks flatten the ground to make room
for even more facilities.
- We're adjusting to the supply
and demand imbalance right now
with the simple answer of just build.
- [Narrator] This site is just one example
of the more than 3.8 million square feet
of warehouse space under
construction in Laredo.
That amounts to a 28%
increase in space since 2012,
according to CoStar, a
real estate analytics firm.
But with warehouses
more than 97% occupied,
companies are struggling
to keep up with demand.
- It is actually an unhealthy
market because there're a lot
of businesses in this
market that want to grow.
- [Narrator] As manufacturing
shifts south of the border,
it is creating job
opportunities in the US.
That's because components
for certain equipment
are often made in Mexico
but need a more skilled labor
force for final assembly.
- The automotive and the
electronic will oftentimes go back
and forth across the Mexico-US
border four, five, six times
before the finished
product is finally ready
for the US consumer.
- [Narrator] While the boom
in trade between the US
and Mexico might mean a smaller
slice of the pie for China,
executives and economists say
it will still remain a dominant supplier
for a vast range of goods.
In the meantime, the trade
passing through Laredo
is projected to grow.
- What the numbers and data tell us
is that the port of Laredo
is gonna keep on growing.
It's just so in a league in by itself
compared to other ports of entry,
it's gonna be hard to compete with Laredo.
(pensive music)